Speaker 1: So Republicans have blocked even
debating and discussing this major voting
rights bill that we've been talking about
now for quite some time, and we are really
now getting into sort of the most disgusting
and destructive of American politics.
And, of course, huge blame goes directly to
the Republicans who voted against even debating
the voting rights bill.
But also, we can't ignore the fact that the
great negotiation that Joe Biden has claimed
he would be able to do has not even led to
a debate about the voting rights bill.
And we're going to have video from the floor
of the Senate and and much more.
And in fact, maybe we'll even start there.
This is the moment where Kamala Harris, who
presided over the Senate during this vote,
announced that the bill was it wasn't we were
not moving forward into debate.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Yays are 50, the nays are fifty
three fifths of the senators duly chosen and
sworn not having voted in the affirmative,
the motion is not agreed to.
Speaker 1: Now, what you have to understand
when you evaluate this is that there really
are two completely different realities on
this issue.
Mitch McConnell, for example, came out and
said we don't even really have a voting rights
issue in this country.
There aren't even people trying to suppress
the ability of individuals to vote.
He said this, I guess with for Mitch McConnell
counts as a straight face.
Let's take a look at what Mitch McConnell
had to say.
I mean, how do you say this with a straight
face?
How do you have the gumption and I mean the
tolerance for cringe to come out and say the
following?
Speaker 3: And many of you have written about
the subject of big lies.
The biggest lie being told in American politics
in recent weeks has been that the states are
involved in a systematic effort to suppress
the vote.
Speaker 1: That's just a wash.
Why would anyone think that that's going on?
I mean, other than the fact that Republicans
have been openly admitting it since at least
2012 when Mike Turzai said voter ID is going
to make it so that Mitt Romney wins Pennsylvania
and then everything else that happened in
the nine years that followed and the two hundred
and fifty something bills across the country,
Speaker 3: those arguments are being made
by people who obviously haven't read any of
these new state laws because that's not happening.
As we all know, we had the biggest turnout
last year since nineteen hundred.
Speaker 1: Now, that's a red herring.
That's a complete and total, very biggest
turnout since 1900.
How many people lived in the United States
in 1900?
So there's three or four different reasons
why that's not a good argument.
Number one, as the population continues to
get larger and larger, you would expect more
and more people to vote.
Trump often points to, hey, I got 75 million
votes.
He really got 74 that you know, that that
makes it hard to believe that I lost, given
that 74 million people voted for me.
Well, even more people voted for Joe Biden.
And in addition to that, we don't know how
many people wanted to vote.
So it's just a complete and total red herring.
Let's just look at a little bit more of this.
Speaker 3: There is no effort in any state
in America to suppress votes based upon.
Suppression of minority participation.
Speaker 1: So that's a complete and total
lie.
I mean, it couldn't be it couldn't be a more
dishonest thing to say.
So let's look at a little bit of the reporting
about this CNN reporting.
Senate Republicans blocked signature Democratic
election bill in key test vote, saying that
Senate Democrats suffered a loss when Republican
opposition sunk their signature voting an
election bill during a key test vote, underscoring
the limits of the party's power with the narrowest
possible Senate majority.
A procedural vote to open debate was defeated
by 50 50, falling short of the 60 votes needed.
Democrats were united in favor after securing
Joe Manchin support, but Republicans were
united against it, causing the measure to
fail to advance.
Democratic senators have pitched the legislation
as a necessary counter to state level efforts
to restrict voting access.
Republicans have decried it as a partizan
power grab and a federal overreach into state
voting and election systems.
The article goes on to say, Senate Democrats
are already beginning to map out their next
steps to draw attention to the issue and put
the focus on a critical battleground state,
Georgia.
Now, one of the lies that they are already
telling about Georgia is, hey, listen, voter
purges are normal.
This is one of the techniques or tactics that
is being used by Republicans to hurt Democrats
in elections.
And it is to purge voter rolls, but to say
every state does it.
Now, it's true that every state does it, but
with far less restrictive barometer's than
what Georgia is putting in place.
And so you really have to look at the details.
And this is one of those issues where if you're
not following it relatively closely, you're
not going to understand why the bullet points
from Republicans fall short.
And this everybody does it.
One is is really a an important example, an
illuminating example, which is they insist
every state has a system for deciding who
should no longer be considered an active registered
voter.
And it depends on how recently you have voted
and other factors.
What's being done in Georgia is far more aggressive
and it's being done in a very tailored way
that while in an overt way it doesn't target
minority voters, it's focused on those more
likely to be voting for Democrats who happen
to disproportionately be nonwhite voters.
So I get it.
People are busy, people are working, people
have lives.
So unless you're following it closely, you
would not necessarily understand why the claims
that are being made are so deceptive.
Now, I want to talk about one other thing
here, which is the filibuster aspect of this.
There is a good article in the L.A. Times,
an editorial by the Times editorial board
which says Senate Republicans won't even consider
voting rights.
The filibuster must go.
And it makes sense that there is increased
pressure to do away with or modify the filibuster
because it's not even that they're voting
against the bill.
They're voting against debating the bill.
And you need 60 votes in order to move forward,
they wrote yesterday.
As expected, debate on a bill to protect voting
rights was blocked in the Senate when Democratic
sponsors failed to garner 60 votes.
But in reaching out to centrist Joe Manchin,
Democrats indicated they were open to compromise.
The shameful reaction of Senate Republicans,
on the other hand, demonstrated that they
are willing to ignore laws approved by Republican
controlled legislatures that make voting harder.
Those measures reflect the lingering malign
influence of Donald Trump's big lie that the
2020 election was stolen.
They go on to say about the filibuster, and
I want to find the exact point where that
is.
After Tuesday's votes, Schumer said that it
represented the starting gun, not the finish
line.
Manchin and other and another Democratic senator,
Kirsten Sinema of Arizona, have resisted the
idea of abolishing the filibuster.
But if Republican senators continue to stonewall
reasonable legislation to protect the right
to vote, those two reluctant Democrats must
be pressed to recognize that at least we're
protecting democracy is concerned.
The filibuster must go.
And this is absolutely and totally correct.
Now, whether the filibuster must go in total,
which potentially is going to have repercussions
against Democrats when Republicans invariably
take control again, at least in practical
terms, you either need to reform it to require
a talking filibuster.
You either need to require the 40 no votes
to be in the Senate at all times in order
to continue with something absolutely has
to be done.
I think at this point it's been clear, you
know, if Republicans and Democrats were equal
in their willingness.
To do whatever needs to be done to move a
bill forward, then maybe we wouldn't be having
this conversation.
But Democrats have shown that they are not
willing to do what needs to be done in the
way that Republicans are to get moving forward
on legislation that they claim is important
to them.
So something is going to have to be done to
the filibuster.
It absolutely is.
Time and again, if Republicans said we believe
we have a really strong case, why this bill
should not pass and we plan not to support
it.
But let's debate the bill and then make their
case against the bill during the debate, I
would have a different perspective, but they're
saying no to even debating the bill.
Something has to be done and the filibuster
is going to have to be a big piece
of that.